Hayato: Hello.
Daniel: Just 1 second.
I'll make sure it's going.
It's all good.
All right, welcome to both.
It is June 13 at zero UTC.
We're here in active guest stream number
44.1 with Hayata Saigo and Nasugu Suchiya.
.
So we're looking forward to this
presentation and discussion.
Hayato, please say hello, and then we'll
continue with Nasuku's presentation.
Hayato: Hello, I'm Hayato Saigo.
I'm a mathematician and a mathematical
physicist also interested in
consciousness; and have worked a lot with
Nao, by using category theory and the
application to IIT or other consciousness
theories. So, Nao?
Nao: All right. So, my name is Nao
Tsuchiya.
I'm a professor in Monash University and
also having a lab in ATR in Japan.
And as a sort of introduction to this
today's session, I will give a brief talk
on our recent project called the Choreo
Structure, which Ayaton and I will be
collaborating and also a little bit on
the quantum quality hypothesis.
Both of them are hopefully relevant to
active inference issue.
So the Quota Structure project is the
Japanese funding that we received
recently, and it's going to continue for
five years.
This will be to establish a super
interdisciplinary research program to
tackle the program of consciousness,
especially qualia through the
interdisciplinary research.
We are planning to also host summer
school for two to three weeks every year.
.
And here's the fantastic members for this
grant.
And Hayato is basically working with me
in the part of the mathematical approach
to the consciousness and aquaria.
One of the problems, for example, we want
to address is, for example, when you see
this square, Daniel, what do you see
here?
Daniel: Blue.
Nao: Yeah, so you say blue, and I say
maybe owl in Japanese, and the Haito may
say sunny in Russian.
But we could mean the same experience
quadria.
But how do we know that we are actually
experiencing the same thing?
And I'm actually curious whether this
kind of question is something that free
energy or active inference kind of style
approach can ever tackle.
And my approach is to go into the
category theory kind of inspired
direction.
And here's the first study that published.
.
We published in a few years ago with
Ayato and the Shigeru, together with also
the another category theorist, the Steve
Phillips, that in the category theory.
There is an interesting lemma called the
Yona Dilemma that proves that all the
relationship characterize its internal
intrinsic property.
And we are using that idea to study the
Chore.
That's the kind of inspiration of our
approach.
So instead of trying to characterize what
the blue is or red is, we are trying to
characterize all the relationship between
a particular color or particular quota to
other exhaustive.
And then by finding the correspondence of
this relationship, we try to identify
what the actual blue is.
So if you say blue is similar to green
but also similar to red, then that's
going to be very different from my blue.
And that's the way how we detect this
blueness, it's same or different.
And one recent application of this kind
of idea is this unsupervised alignment
that we are using with another
collaborator, Masafumi Oism in University
Tokyo.
And I'll skip the detail, but basically
what we are doing is to do some kind of
experiment and then collect lots of data
to obtain so called similarity matrix
between all the colors and then without
really knowing what color maps onto what
we try to use on the relationship to
predict what we are seeing.
So in a sense, this is a pure category
theoretical kind of approach to the
problem of consciousness.
Then I'll just skip the details here.
So we are doing this kind of approach on
other types of aquaria and then this is
the thing that we are planning to do for
next five years.
And then another just brief kind of
introduction.
If you have some other question, we can
come back later.
So this is potentially more to do with an
active inference aspect of our approach
in a sense.
And this is called the Quantum Courier
hypothesis.
We published this preprint really
recently and so you can access it later.
So one of the there are many programs in
the current models of our chore or
consciousness where we tend to think that
experience or consciousness is like one
point in the high dimensional space.
And we use that kind of idea for our
previous alignment experiment approach,
but it lacks dynamics and it also lacks
the effects that we tend to experience
where the observation or report or
introspection itself sometimes change our
chore, right?
And that's sort of the active inference
aspect that I'm talking about.
Attention or introspection changes
experience.
But traditional approach is very
difficult to deal with this and one way
to deal with that is this quantum
formalism that we think is appropriate.
So here we think that there is some kind
of chorea experiencing system that is
defined as this blue boundary.
You can consider that as sort of the
Markov blanket like thing in the free
energy kind of idea.
And then we consider particular type of
the quail like redness or blueness itself
as an observable.
It's a terminology in quantum theory.
Something that in principle can be
observed within this quarry.
And then we consider this measurement as
a process that probe this quadrilateral
observable.
And unlike classical theoretical thinking,
, we think that the measurement or
probing of this observable through it's
called a state, changes its state and
also observable itself.
And that's something that we can actually
formalize mathematically using a concept
called a very general concept of this
conditional probability called instrument.
.
It's very technical for the quick talk,
so I'll leave it.
But this is a modern quantum theoretical
idea that captures both how we can affect
on the world and the quota itself can be
affected by that measurement.
And then using this we think that we can
explain probably quota in a much more
reasonable way with the mathematics
mathematical formalism, and so far, it's
just a kind of theory, but we already
think that it's probably better than the
existing kind of a model of, for example,
attention and the consciousness.
And also it also provides some kind of
prediction and the explanation of why
some of the two concepts or two
experience can feel different depending
on the order that you experience.
So this is just like conceptual kind of
example.
But if I ask you, Daniel, that is China
similar to North Korea?
Then you might say probably no.
Right.
Daniel: I don't even know the reference
point.
Nao: Yeah, okay.
But let's say just subjectively, china
doesn't feel similar to North Korea.
Daniel: Okay.
Nao: Yeah.
However, if I reverse the order, is now
North Korea similar to China, then many
people actually start to say that, yeah,
it's kind of similar.
Daniel: Does that have to do with one
being larger or what?
Is it about the order that primes people
to respond differently?
Nao: Yeah, so many people have already
came up with many different kind of ideas
to explain this kind of individual
aspects of this order effect.
But as we mentioned, we are actually
computing or measuring these kind of
order effects systematically through all
combination of the colors, for example.
Then it's hard to systematically explain
why this order effect emerges in one
cases but not the other, and in which
direction.
Right, but that's what we found,
basically.
And but using this in a quantum cognition
kind of framework, we can explain it
really nicely.
In this case, it's just a projection
postrate, but we are probably going to
extend much more in the more instrument
like framework in the future.
Yeah.
And also we are also predicting that
there may be some kind of.
Violation.
Of inequality like situation in
perception.
And if we can confirm that, that also
gives a credence to our proposal that the
quality needs to be framed or explained
in the quantum framework.
So I think that's probably enough to
start up the conversation, I guess.
Daniel: Awesome.
Okay, great lot to jump into.
Hayato: I'll.
Daniel: Share my screen so we can take
some notes.
Okay.
Hato, do you want to give a first remark
or I'm happy to, but do you have a first
remark or what parts of the work do you
want to reflect on first?
Hayato: I think maybe the Categorical
approach.
The importance of Categorical approach is
one issue to talk with you, I think,
because you first pointed out that paper
with Shiger Tabuchi 2016.
So I'm interested in why you and your
colleague are interested in that paper
from the active inference side.
So can you explain some feeling?
Daniel: Yes.
So this is using category theory to
assess the relationship between
consciousness and integrated information
theory with the two of you and Taguchi
from 2016.
So I've long been interested in scale
free or scale independent ways to
describe systems and information theory
has been recognized as one of those
approaches.
And information theory has been proposed
to not just play, of course, a central
role in the functionality of information
systems, but with IIT and related
theorems to also strike at the heart of
the most quintessential aspect of our
conscious experience.
So that seems like an incredible
synthesis of the functionality of systems
that don't necessarily seem to have
anything qualia like at all merely
performing calculations like a super fast
abacus basically.
And so I am curious and feel free to
address either of these things.
When we describe information systems,
what is it that would or could or is
experienced?
Are they experiencing their information,
what they are processing or what is it
about?
Information integration would grant a
system the ability to move beyond a
behavioral functionality into again
strike at the heart of one of the most
ineffable questions that the mind can
really consider.
Hayato: Okay, interesting actually the
category itself in mathematics originated
created in mid 20th century to bridge the
two different fields, that is geometry
and algebra, more specifically the
topology.
You know something about topology maybe
which is a very general kind of
mathematical mesos to capture the essence
of the figures like a circle or
complicated figures.
And the fundamental problem of the
topology is can you identify the two
different figures?
Essentially that means can you transform
continuously to the other figures or
not?
So if the one figure goes to another
figure with a continuous transformation
and back then it is viewed as essentially
the same.
But to determine the two figures same is
a very difficult question.
So like great mathematician figured out
the utility of the algebraic method that
like making the one figure to the other
from the figure you can construct the
algebra system like groups or something
and then the transform the program into
the algebra region.
Then the point is very essential point is
taking one figure to constructing one
algebra from the one figure is not
sufficient.
The point is the relation should be
transformed the other regions.
So one region here, other regions here
but one to one correspondence of object
is not sufficiently but the relations if
you can transform the order relations
into the other regions then you can prove
something from one region to another
region.
Because this is a notion of the function
like the region intuitively I talked
about using term the region.
It is mathematically called category.
Category consists of objects and arrows,
arrows or morphism which is a generate
kind of relationship between these
objects.
So topological region is some kind of
category of topology like a top that
objects topological space and continuous
functions, continuous mapping is ro or
something.
There are other regions, for example RGB
region like groups and group homophism or
the module vector space or something.
So something RJ rack and the relationship
between them.
So category is defined to formulate the
intuitive concept of bridging something
functor.
So first the Island Bag and Macbrain
defined category to define this notion of
functor by the bridging to region.
Then, if this is established, then you
can infer about the topological region
category by using the algebra relation or
something.
So we that is now Shiger and me talked
about the possible application of this
kind of argument into the consciousness
study that it is just a program of
bridging different kind of regions like
physically testable region and our role
experience itself or something so it is
apolia it seems apolia it is too
difficult question too hard problem to
connect to these regions but if you only
focus on the object but the relationship
if you can compare the relationship then
you can infer something about you cannot
directly touch or you directly manipulate.
.
So this is the idea.
Nao: Maybe I'll just add a little bit.
As Hyatt said, you are taking really
diligent notes.
So that may be quite a good but from my
end.
So this paper was inspired by really
talking to Hayato Shigaru and the meeting
in this summer school on consciousness.
And there I encountered in this category
theory for the first time.
And there were several shocking kind of
concepts that I learned from this first
encounter.
One is that there isn't a way to compare
two completely different things and then
extract common structure between them.
And Hayato first introduced me this very
strange paper which I didn't understand
at all, but was so interesting that I
could read for hours and hours.
It's called the Rosetta Stone.
It points out commonality between the
topology, quantum physics, logic and
computation.
That was the title.
And then I didn't understand what the.
Heck is this in a paper, but that uses
this category theory.
And as a whole, I feel like I see.
So maybe if we understand the structure
behind each of this concrete example, we
may be able to find a commonality or
explanation at that level.
And that naturally applied to my program
at the time, which is how to bridge the
gap between the quotia and the
information structure derived from neural
activity.
This looks also completely different.
But if there is any possibility to bridge
the gap, it must be some kind of
structural mathematics, and that is
category theory.
Hayato: Another point is that I think you
can get the ideas of functions by
breathing the two regions.
Then the really interesting thing,
another really interesting concept is
called natural transformation.
Natural transformation is the kind of
deformation or transformation between
transformation.
So you imagine some theory bridge some
addition to the another region.
So there is one meta level arrow code but
another theory predicts another thing or
something.
But can you connect these theories or
models?
This is a problem of natural
transformation so one representation, one
theory or something may map the one
region to another region but there may be
another various kind of mappings factors
so the problem is to compare or to unite
to connect this transformation function
is called natural transformation.
If the function is naturally isomorphic,
that means there is a reversible natural
transformation between functions.
Then these theories seems different but
essentially same.
So kind of natural transformation is
maybe the hint to connect the various
theories on consciousness or something.
And also our consciousness experience
itself will be connected to the concept
of natural transformation.
Because I see something that the
different thing, something.
But there is no divided discrete kind of
structure, but there is some continuous
or relating something.
So this is this view is something like
function.
Another view is something like function,
but there is no division.
There is some relationship.
So our experience maybe itself a kind of
product of a natural transformation.
Like, maybe now you can explain, like a
periphery or maybe no, you are muted.
Muted.
Nao: Is it all right if I draw some kind
of figure?
Daniel: Of course.
Would you like to share your screen?
Hayato: Yeah.
Nao: And also if you can give me the
access to the annotation okay.
Daniel: I will make it so everyone can
edit and I'll put it into the chat here.
And then also if you want to draw, that
would be awesome.
Hayato: Yeah.
Nao: Do you see the whiteboard now?
Daniel: Looks good.
Hayato: Yeah.
Nao: So just to kind of recap, what Hyatt
was talking about is that we tend to
think about something like a category,
and then another category is there.
And then there is some kind of object
which could be quite abstract.
And then it's related by arrow like this.
.
And then if this category C is somehow
possible to map onto this category D
while kind of preserving this arrow.
For example, this arrow goes to here, and
then this arrow goes to here.
And then each object is also preserved.
Then it's much more than the usual kind
of idea of a function between the sets.
Right.
Because it also impose the correspondence
between the relationship.
And in our idea, basically, if this is,
let's say, Claudia of the category, and
if this is a neuronal activity or maybe
information domain, and then maybe we can
have a back and forth of the factor, that
would be great.
Usually most of the mathematical theory
of consciousness tries to go from here to
here, right?
Let's say in the case of IIT arrow here,
and then what Hyatt was kind of talking
in a way as natural transformation is
this kind of secondary level arrow.
Let's say.
I don't know whether free energy or
active inference can count as a
prediction from neural activity to the
particular quadria, but let's say if
there is something like that, and then
maybe there is some kind of a translation
between these two theories.
Yeah.
If that exists, that's called a natural
transformation.
Daniel: Awesome.
A few comments on this.
The idea of mapping the maps between the
spaces is so important.
It reminds me of metaphor where we're
conveying relationships and saying, well,
it's like a hammer, or it is a hammer.
For this other situation.
So that's how we get few shot learning
and applicability and how we grasp
concepts is perhaps developmentally or
from an evolutionary perspective in a
large extent by generalizing our spatial
and embodied understandings and then
certainly communication.
If you want to have some semantics that
are being communicated across minds,
through an interface, through a classical
interface, then certainly you want the
structure to be preserved.
And then I think the one that you have
here is one of the most provocative for
those empirically studying consciousness
because it's kind of like this side is
empirical and let's just say we don't
know what the Q side is for now, but let'
's just say it's another space that isn't
that.
And then if there is a certain landscape
that neural activity patterns flow
through like some kind of winnerless
competition or you get some sort of limit
cycle and you find that there's a limit
cycle of neural activity and then there's
also that is being paralleled by
experiential cycles, then that is not
just an accounting system.
That's a very strong finding about
potentially the real underlying causal
system, especially because it can suggest
unique other explanations or
manipulations to make right.
Nao: Do you want to mention anything
about the metaphor?
Hayato: Yeah, before that very hard to
say.
The technical remark is that for the
original problem that connects topology
and algebra, then in that case the
algebra is more concrete, more
manipulative in that case.
And the topology is something mysterious
in this case.
So in general the function is a kind of
generalization mapping in sets.
So there's something mysterious into
something concrete.
So now picture C and D should be switched
maybe in that case.
But of course there is a back and maybe
back and forth.
So the idea is your brew and my brew
program is for example, you can prove
that your brew and my brew is different.
If there's something, informational or
something, the detectable structure is
completely different, then your brew and
my brew is different.
Of course you cannot prove the sameness
between your brew and my brew if there is
no how to say the back and forth function.
.
But even if you don't have the backwards
function, at least you can demonstrate
that your brew and my brew is different,
seems to be different if the
correspondence is functional or something.
.
So it is a big step from the experience
side and with me and colleagues do such a
thing.
So this is not by focusing your brew, my
brew only, but your brew read something
or you don't have to say, even do not
have to say the name of something.
So just how to say no labeling for
example, but the relationship you can
teach the relationship these things.
You can teach the relationship these
things.
So then compare that so very
interestingly.
In general the structure is surprisingly
coherent between persons.
It is very nice and also maybe it's
suggesting that the known isomorphic case,
, then your brew and my brew is something
different or something.
So I think this approach is very
interesting even if there's no
BioDirection or only one direction, but
even that case it is useful.
Yeah, it is my remark.
Daniel: Yeah, please.
And then I'll have a question about your
drawing.
Nao: Right.
So this is one of the slides that I didn'
't show today.
But what Hyatt was talking about is kind
of explaining this figure.
Like the way you experience red is
related to with the other experience, not
only color but shape and also sound and
so on in a very complicated way.
And then we can actually measure how
similar they are by asking the people and
then you can also do that for the other
people.
And then these two similarity metrics can
be directly compared with our new method
of this unsupervised running.
And also IIT, for example, may allow us
in the future to go back and forth
between this quoria structure and the
information structure.
Mathematically, we believe that the
information structure to information
structure should be potentially
translatable in some way.
And if that is possible in some way,
eventually we may be able to say, okay,
so the way you are experienced red is
same or different in this way or that way.
.
That's sort of the idea.
Daniel: Can you go back to your drawing?
Nao: Right.
Daniel: Awesome.
So for the top arrow, if we're kind of
just exploring, what might it mean that
IIT is going back and forth and also that
active inference is going back and forth.
.
So what exactly does the edge between C
and D represent in IIT?
Is that a quantitative evaluation like
the five variable or what is being
accounted for with that arrow?
Nao: Do you want to say something?
Hayato: Yeah.
There is various possibilities actually.
For example, the sameness or difference.
So if you have some kind of gradation
with sameness, sameness gradation but to
formulate the gradation of sameness, you
have to move on the enriched category.
Not a simple kind of category, but it's a
generalized kind of category called
enriched category.
In that case, for example, the simplest
example for enriched category is
generalized generalized metric space.
Metric.
In metric space, for example, the point P
and P itself has a distance zero of
course, and kind of P two Q, two R is
there is a triangular inequality or
something.
Then it can be considered as a
generalized kind of compositional
structure called enriched category.
It is a typical kind of enriched category,
, but symmetry does not always hold or
something.
So this is one, how to say, one small
step to grasp our Korea structure.
Because like now pointed out, North Korea
China distance and the China North Korea
distance is in general different or
something.
So almost all studies assume that some
symmetry.
But we need to go beyond that.
And then maybe the one number or
something is too poor to represent
everything.
So you have to go more and more richer
structure, like not just numbers but some
kind of projection operator or something.
.
Then you enter into the quantum region.
So relationship we feel should be maybe
should be represented from some kind of
relationship between the notion of state
in quantum theory and the state
transition between that.
So our approach is step by step and you
can choose the many arrows to study
something and then goes to unify the more
and more general kind of arrows and
categories.
And this is just for the speculation but
this kind of quantum theoretical like as
a mathematical framework do not need to
the kind of physics but the kind of
mathematics can you use unify these kind
things.
Daniel: Awesome.
Just a few comments on that.
When we're doing free energy minimization,
, we use the KL divergence which is very
importantly not a distance because a
distance would have the symmetry
characteristic.
And so the KL is chosen because it's easy
to fit optimization on these variational
distributions, but it's almost like it's
a feature, not a bug, that the KL
divergence between Q and p is not the
same as P and q, because it turns out
that that kind of a divergence based
quantification actually has some
advantages over a distance measure.
And then the mapping between observables
and hidden states and the cognitive
operators that we bring to bear on that
kind of mapping problem.
Those are some of the most fundamental
pieces of the partially observable Markov
decision processes that are used in the
active inference generative model, which
is first the mapping between observables
and hidden states and then how do hidden
states change through time and how does
action selection, policy selection
influence how hidden states unfold
through time?
So this mapping between hidden states and
observables and between hidden states and
the hidden state at the next time point
and again how action influences that.
If you understand those operations, then
it's like a game of chess and the ball
just rolls downhill and the variational
distribution works exceedingly well.
But when those are off base, then you're
fitting your way like right off a cliff.
Nao: So maybe then I'll just add one more
point.
So you asked in the original like five
minutes ago what each of these points or
arrow correspond to in the case of the
IIT and so on.
And then this is kind of related to all
these ideas.
But one of the fundamental insights from
IIT but also from philosophy, especially
some kind of philosophy called the
process theory is it is important to
really understand that the process of
flow or movement is really fundamentally
important kind of aspect of things.
And then that may be really
distinguishing some kind of static set or
the thing in the static world when they
start to interact.
And when the process emerge then
something starts to potentially generate
or support subjective quality like
protocol kind of thing.
And in the case of the IAT, it is deeply
kind of entrenched in this formation of
the transition probability matrix of an
entity like how this thing neuron or
logic gate, it might have come from the
previous state and it may go into the
next state.
So any kind of a moment is already
embedding the possible previous and the
possible future.
There is some kind of a with us in the
moment because it's a process.
And when the process is considered, then
as I have said, that this kind of dot is
a very kind of two thing kind of
structure to think about.
So we need a more elaborated structure of
a dot itself.
But the category theory is great in the
sense that each dot can itself contain
complicated structure.
It's just represented as a single dot but
it can contain something more.
Right?
So in an upshot, one dot could correspond
to a collection of the neuronal states
and the connectivity pattern and things
like that, which can go from one to the
other.
And then this kind of movement may
correspond to something like we see
redness or whatever in this way but that'
's also with respect to other kind of
arrows as well.
And that's the sort of wave of the
relationship that we are trying to
characterize both in the domain but
aquaria, but also brain is also the wave
of the relationship, gigantic ones,
right?
And as you said, that transition from one
state to the another state that's pretty
much like dynamical system like approach
and then the simple idea called a monoid
is applicable to this kind of dynamical
system approach.
Correct me Hayato, if I'm saying
something out of the bounds of my comfort
zone, but any kind of state can
transition into another state and then
this transition itself can be represented
by the arrow.
The combination of that particular kind
of arrow composition may correspond to
one experience.
So that's one thing I wanted to say.
The other thing that I had also mentioned
about observable state and why we are
interested in a quantum framework,
quantum theory, by the way, it's not a
quantum brain hypothesis.
We are not saying that quantum phenomena
in the brain is critical for
consciousness, but it's just a
mathematical structure of the quantum
theory that is important to understand
the quota.
And the essence is most likely to be this
noncommutativity any kind of process that
you do, like cooking, putting the water
and then model is different from model
and then putting water.
Right?
And so any kind of process we do, there
is some kind of temporal dependency that
commutativity doesn't hold and that's
also probably the case for the quota.
And if that's the case, then for you
maybe it's a bit surprising, but Bayesian
kind of statistics and Bayesian
probability may not work as you might
wish.
Hayato: Yes.
So in other words, using the Kanam
mathematics there is a quite good
generalization of Bayesian.
Innovation kind of inference.
Yes, actually the one step generalization
is called a projection in kind of
mathematics.
Then there is more generalization called
instrument.
So instrument is general notion of
measurements like a system and
environment interacting.
Then more precisely, the measurement is
something like the interaction feature
has some probe over the apparatus.
So probe is some kind of the apparatus is
some very small tips or something which
can be considered as a quantum that this
quantum system and this probe system
interacting quantumly, then we can
measure this probe by the macro side of
the apparatus.
So this is a very general kind of
measurement which is identified
mathematically with the notion of
instrument originated by the Davis and
Lewis and Ozawar, one of our
collaborators.
We begin in the collaboration, but Ozawar,
, who is also famous for the Ozawa's
inequality, Ozawa inequality as a
generalization of Heisen belt universally
valid version of Heisen magazine
inequality.
But he identified this general notion
measurement and instrument called a
completely positive instrument in
mathematics.
But this CP completely positive
instrument is quite general and
generalizing very beautifully the
Bayesian inference into the quantum side.
.
So I think focusing this kind of
instrument kind of concept is the key
maybe to bridge the active inference side
on our side and quantum side or something.
.
So, yeah, it is my speculation, but I
think it is very fruitful direction.
Daniel: It's awesome.
Just one comment on that.
The probe with the instrument or the
quantum reference frame, I believe, as
Chris Fields might describe it, is an
experimenter's choice.
And so the way that we could talk about
policy selection and inference on which
experiment to run would be in terms of
which sequence of observations is going
to minimize expected free energy.
So which sequence of observations is
going to have high pragmatic value and
epistemic value that's the expected free
energy functional.
Now, as researchers, we might seek out
the most informative experiments and not
prefer to see a certain measurement.
So we can say, well, all measurements are
a priori equally pragmatically valuable
to us.
So now expected free energy is going to
be driven by information maximization
just by pure learning.
But this recognition that action is woven
into the process of reducing uncertainty
about other systems across blankets.
It's absolutely fundamental, because if
you don't have the constraint that you
need to actively select which experiments
to run and to probe and to interfere in
this quantum way, this way described by
quantum mathematics, you're kind of in a
delusional alternative world where you
get information from photons, but you don'
't have a sensor.
So it's not an empirically tractable
world unless we take on this constraint.
And then once we do, our mathematics are
the quantum mathematics.
And again, it's kind of a subtle point.
This isn't the ORC or this isn't
necessarily taking a stance one way or
the other on what kinds of electronic
scale quantum phenomena exists in any
system, but rather just sees quantum
mathematics as fundamental to decision
making and uncertainty, which is quite a
change from how it's been discussed for
100 years.
Hayato: Actually, as now said, we are not
dependent on the hypothesis.
Like there is a quantum physical process
behind the courier.
But why we can use the quantum mathematic
is very simple reason.
Because conventional probability theory,
classical probability theory depend on
the probability space.
Classical one is too narrow to capture,
for example, order effect or something.
But you can generalize it.
So quantum mathematics is just
generalized the Crasco mathematics.
And I believe that why quantum
mathematics is found for quantum physics
is a very simple reason because in Crasco
physics, some kind of determinism.
Determinism is very universal and the
probability only comes from some kind of
ignorance of us.
But in quantum physical context there is
some kind of very fundamental randomness.
.
The fundamental accidents or something is
found and they are all surprised because
if you go into the microsite, the
determinism should be stronger and
stronger they sold.
But actually there needs some kind they
found fundamental noncommutativity and
microside.
But who?
Isabel Bohr and Heisenberg some people
pointed out that Evening Grascow or
Evening sorry, a macroscopic side.
But this kind of the importance of
noncommutativity is very universal, not
especially in microsite, but it is a
historical reason that we first find in
mathematics in the microsite.
But there is many, many phenomena which
cannot be captured by the determinism or
the classical probability theory.
So I think the courier or something is
just some kind of.
Nao: Example.
Hayato: Yeah, example, yes.
Nao: By the way, maybe Daniel, can you
replace this quantum consciousness with
the quantum quadria?
Daniel: Yes.
Nao: So the quantum consciousness has
been used to imply this quantum brain
hypothesis, which may be potentially true,
, but so far we don't really see the
strong evidence about this particular
thing.
Daniel: What's funny, I'm thinking of the
classic qualia question what is it like
to be a bat?
And it's like, what if the like is
interpreted as a metaphor?
What if there's a metaphorical mapping to
bat which is an observer dependent
mapping amongst spaces?
Because we've moved the focus from the
objective standalone experience of the
bat to considering mappings amongst
cognitive systems, one critical, one
being, for example, whoever's listening
to the question and a bat who's the one
who actually answers that question.
Nao: Okay, so you asked also about the
inspiration from the category theory
relevant to the issue of the metaphor,
right?
And also communication.
Now, it's a bit far from this quantum
corey and they jump back to another topic.
.
Metaphor is something that the Hiato has
been working on.
So yeah, but the other part, which is
this communication.
And that's something that we also wrote
together last year and using this concept
called adjunction in category theory,
which may be also interesting to discuss.
.
So in 2016 paper we already mentioned
that category theory is very promising
for the study of consciousness precisely
because it provides different levels of
sameness.
When I heard this from Hayato, I was like
what do you mean?
But as simultaneously it makes a lot of
sense and in fact many controversy or
confusion among the field of
consciousness.
But not only for consciousness.
Other fields like ecology as well like
classification of the animal species and
things like that all depends on this.
What do you mean by the same?
Right?
And this is something that also relates
to what you are talking about a moment
ago, which is observer dependence,
right?
Even at the very bottom of this reality,
I think that what matters is some notion
of this subjective choice of what it
means to be the same.
Equivalence or adjunction is a
particularly interesting kind of
situation where, for example, integer and
the real number is definitely different.
But in terms of the relationship, if you
start to think about the relationship,
there is some kind of one to one
correspondence between them.
And also Hayato's book, also written in
Japanese, but recently I did read it and
one of the interesting example is also
multiplication and exponentiation at the
level of object or number it doesn't
match, right?
But there is a very nice relationship
between them that is very fundamental and
something like this apparently completely
different thing but finding really
meaningful relationship that's very
fundamental.
In communication we are talking different
kind of language with different kind of
meaning, but because when I say something,
, you reply and then there is some kind
of systematic difference between what I
expect and what I hear.
That's the kind of prediction error,
right?
I think the prediction error may not need
to be minimized in fact, but as long as
it's consistent and systematic then it
actually works as a very nice
translational kind of device.
After living like 20 years, more than 20
years of living outside of Japan, I still
have very strong English accent, either
in Japanese or Japanese, living in
Australia or US.
I can't minimize this prediction error.
But because I have this systematic
prediction error for you, you totally
understand me, right?
Something like this is the interesting
thing about that junction.
Daniel: This makes me think about nested
reference frames in communication.
And let's just say that the expected free
energy or maybe even the integrated
information content is such and such a
level, but it varies within some range.
It's 100 plus or minus ten.
Instead of just trying to naively
minimize that to zero, we can create a
nested model such that we expect that to
be 100 plus or minus ten, at which point
the non zero value is stabilized or
buffered.
And so then that becomes the kind of
stabilizes or wraps the fact that we're
not perfectly transmitting information
but we can be perfectly aligned, that we'
're not perfectly transmitting
information.
And also our language understanding for
fluent speakers we're able to map the
phonemes a little bit deeper.
We're able to read between the lines or
listen between the phonemes.
So that people who say words differently
map to the exact same syntax, let alone
the semantics.
The sound gets kind of abstracted out,
but it influences our qualia.
So something is being passed forward with
tonality and the timing.
And I wonder about with of course large
language models how much context they're
able to garner from the string of tokens
when for our experience sending and
receiving natural language communication
it's all about the timing and the tone
and the setting.
And so finding ways that we can describe
that type of information, the category
theory capacity for the different levels
of sameness seems like exactly the tool
that we need.
Nao: Do you want to add anything?
Hayato: Yeah, I'm thinking about but.
Nao: About the multilevel kind of free
energy minima.
I actually have a question to you
actually.
So I recently discussed with roboticist
in Japan, Jun Tani, do you know his
work?
Yes is using this predictive coding kind
of scheme for constructing the set of
autonomous robot and he thinks this
intermingle of the top down prediction
and the bottom up prediction error is the
place that Korea emerges and things like
that.
But one of his most interesting aspect of
his model to me is that he has this
different timescale for his neural system.
.
The most peripheral motor level and
sensory level has a very fast time scale.
.
So that tries to match with what's
happening outside and then what they want
to do towards outside.
And the intermediate level has a slightly
longer kind of time scale.
So there is some kind of inertia and an
even higher level has a much much longer
timescale.
In the probably neural system there is
also different level of the timescale and
also different levels of the mechanism
acting at the same time like change in
the activity state in spiking or not and
also release of the snaptick
neurotransmitters that could increase or
decrease over the time and also even the
new neurons emerging and going out.
So.
The minimization, when you are talking
about minimization, probably that kind of
minimization is actually happening
independently and also coherent tree
potentially or contradictory across
different levels and also regions.
And there may be some kind of effort or
whatever to also coordinate these kind of
contradictory demands of the minimization.
.
What do you think about this issue?
Do you still think it's a useful way to
think about or use the term minimization
in this situation?
Daniel: That's a great question.
Well, one thing that stood out to me was
you described the slower moving levels as
having inertia and from the Bayesian
mechanics perspective that's exactly how
we would model it.
They're slower moving, they have more
inertia, and they move more like
classical objects, whereas the faster
timescales are moving more like lighter
particles, more like that quantum probe
in the limit and then the sort of center
or the highest nested model would be like
the most cognitively massive, potentially
the slowest, potentially integrating
information over the longest time window.
.
And certainly this is underlaned by these
multiple timescales of mechanism spiking
neurons from a few hundred milliseconds
timescale neuromodulatory processes over
seconds and minutes, synaptic plasticity
even neurogenesis and the development of
our brain.
So what does it really mean that
minimization is occurring when we have
this heterarchy where we have similar
types of free energy minimizing units or
active inference units within a level
like Cortical columns or grid cell units
and then also we have these nested models
that are optimizing across spatial
temporarily separated scales.
Well, one paper that looked at this was
Our Livestream 42 on the Slam
simultaneous localization and mapping
also in robotics.
And so they had a two nested model with
two steps and the lower level was like
the tactics and that was where you had
the motor and the sensors and then the
nested model was slower that was like
where do I want to be?
That was more like the strategy and you
can create an expected free energy
functional that sums across those two
levels how you tune the parameters is
going to matter because how do you wait
this comes up with preference learning.
If you have left or turn and right turn
and your preference vector is like two
and one versus 2 million and 1 million,
then the ratio of the preference is the
same, but the amplitude of the preference
is a lot different, which is going to
swing the model towards Valuing pragmatic
outcomes.
Whereas if you had zero two and zero one,
the ratio of the preference would still
be the same.
But it's such a small amplitude
preference.
And so similarly, with expected free
energy minimization you could make it so
that the joint minimization was driven by
just the top level of the model.
And then the sort of contradictions or
even increases in expected free energy of
the lower sensory model would basically
always be accepted in service of the top
model or vice versa.
And it seems like biological systems with
their sort of precarious or self
organized criticality operations they're
poised where you can have propagations
where small changes in the bottom up
model can propagate and induce phase
changes of higher levels and vice versa.
So they're certainly poised
parametrically at a special place where
the composition of the faster sensory
motor models and the slower like
cognitive or narrative or metacognitive
levels it's all poised in a very
integrated way, potentially even one that
is where the IIT measures tell us
something useful.
But yes, the contradictory demands of
subunits within a level of collective
behavior and across levels.
As a biologist I think we just point to
ecology, evolution and development and
just distributed systems that don't exist
at an adaptive point or implement
adaptive dynamics amidst uncertainty.
They just fail to exist and so the
complex biological systems that we
observe today do manage that trade off.
And then in robotics, they have this
unique challenge of developing systems
with one shot or with Iterated
development that do have some of those
properties.
But for sure, there's no reason to think
that just by laying out a nested active
inference model that you would actually
get, like, a more adaptive decision
making agent.
In fact, as you nest models, the state
space of these models becomes vast.
And with some back of the envelope
calculations, you can see, like, well, if
I do this level of nesting and have this
kind of sensor array, we need this absurd
amount of data to actually parameterize
this model.
And by the time we collected that many
observations, maybe the causal structure
that we learned to the world, 200 hours
of video ago don't apply.
Nao: Yeah, that could be quite a huge
difference between probably IIT and free
energy.
I think the IIT explicitly states that
this time scale that matters, but in this
case, it's just about quaria is a
particular time scale that maximize
integrated information and that
corresponds to the timescale of our
experience.
Tannis model, the lowest timescale is
like, on the order of 100 seconds or
something like that.
And also new synaptic plasticity is on
the order of hours.
And most likely spiking neurons seems to
be more mattering with respect to our
particular experience at each moment.
Right.
And why it is the case that the
provisional answer provided by IIT is
that because at that particular time
scale, integrated information is much
larger and across the scale and across
the regions.
But this is a huge conjecture, and nobody
knows whether this is true or not.
And when we use the Fly model, we weren't
able to sort of confirm any kind of a
clear peak in the integrated information
using a different time scale.
So it's still something that I'm very
interested in looking, but still not
clear whether this is the case.
I don't know if Hayato has some idea or
insight into the appropriate time scale
for consciousness or something from the
physics point of view.
Hayato: Yeah, I have some thoughts, but
maybe it becomes a long story and also
connects to the observer dependence
program.
So I was thinking about how to explain
these very important things in one thread,
, and I found that first, the very simple
fact that there comes no identically same
two events.
Every event is different in some respect.
.
But to do science, or more generous, some
recognition of law, we need some
criterion of sameness.
For example, you want to know how to heal
the disease?
You should identify the different persons,
, people as the same kind of samples or
something.
Of course, there is no identical persons,
but you have to identify in the members
of the same group something.
So all the scientific studies depend on
some choice of the sameness.
And so in that sense, all the science
depends on this kind of choice of the
sameness as you both pointed out and I
think that there is no canonical choice
of the sameness.
You can choose sameness but if you choose
some sameness, then you can talk about
observables.
Observables means some kind of quantities.
.
You can observe something, maybe it
randomly change the value or no value
like a count of case.
But by measuring process it become half
the value or something.
There may be indefinite nature of such
kind of quantities, but anyway we can
imagine that the quantities has some kind
of structure between the quantities.
So in mathematical terms it will be some
algebra of the observables.
Then how to connect this idea theoretical
idea to the experimental thing is the key
is expectation value.
So theory provides expectation value of
something and we can connect theory and
experiments by comparing the theoretical
expectation value and the average of
samples.
So all the quantitative science depends
on this structure like algebra,
observables and some mapping from the
observables algebra to the sum number
system.
So this is called a state in mathematics
and algebra.
And state is something like the mapping
of quantities of random variables or
observables into its expectation value.
So this mapping of expectation is
technically called state.
So if you start from observer algebra and
state, this is a starting point of
noncommutative probability theory.
That is if this algebra is commutative,
then the conventional probability theory
can reconstruct from this commutative
algebra and state.
But if this is noncommutative as now
pointed out, if the process is essential,
then these algebra should be
noncommutative.
Then we have the noncommutativity
probability space features which I code
intuitively the counter mathematics or
something.
So in this case the observable dependence
is described.
The other kind of observable dependence
can be described because you can't have
the classical probability space for all
the observable.
But if you choose one observable, one
observable like position or momentum, you
can choose this.
Then you can construct the classical
probability space.
So the choice of context or the choice of
measuring something is by choosing
something.
So context you can have the classical
kind of reality.
So this kind of observer with dependence
is well formulated by using
noncommutative probability space.
So I think this multilayered observable
observer dependence can be described by
using noncommutative probability.
And the last thing I would say is the
connection of the category theory and
noncommutativity probability.
Very interestingly,
if the category is given like a causal
system causal system give us some
category.
Like a causaliation is arrow, and the
composition is A is cause of B, B causes
C.
Then indirectly of course at least the A
causes C or something, so it becomes can
be considered as a category.
There is many kind of category. But if
the category is given, then the algebra
refracting this categorical structure is
necessarily noncommutative if there is a
nontrivial arrow between two objects.
So actually the category theory and the
noncommutative probability is from the
mathematical point of view, it's kind of
the two aspects of the same thing, like
the fundamental observer dependence or
contextual dependence or something.
And this contextuality, like in topos
theory, actually, this choosing concepts
and the transformation between the
contexts can be formulated in terms of
topos, which is a very powerful kind of
category.
So sorry for the too-long explanation!
But without that, this very fundamental
question cannot be organized.
Sorry for the long explanation.
Daniel: Oh, it's it's awesome.
I mean, empirically, if you have a sensor
that's getting measurements at a certain
time scale, then there's a binding of the
timescale of the observer and the
processing.
Can I ask a question from the chat?
All right.
Dave asks.
At one time, Professor Tononi was
representing the shape of the relations
between complexity and consciousness,
such that too-richly-connected systems
are nonconscious.
They're overwhelmed by the complexity.
Recently, the inverted U that shows this
relation seems to have become scarce,
leading to undue confusion.
Have IIT people abandoned the idea that
there is a bounded sweet zone for
consciousness?
Can a system be either too simple or too
complex to act consciously?
So is IIT lead us to a kind of monotonic
consciousness concept, or could there be
a U shaped relationship with information
integration and qualia?
Nao: I see.
Yeah.
I can also see that comment here.
In the end, the question is, can the
system be either too simple or too
complex to act consciously?
Daniel: Right.
Nao: In the sense yeah, from an IAT point
of view, there are several things that
needs to be said, but inverted U is still
there in a sense.
And here this person seems to be
confusing between the axis of the kind of
complexity and the axis of the
connectedness. In IIT original
formulation -
and it's still true for the IIT 4.0,
which is the latest one - when the system
is too connected, let's say if you have
hundred neurons and each of them are
connected to everybody in a uniform way,
then IIT predicts that it doesn't have
much complexity or compositionality or
uniqueness to arrive from that kind of
system.
And even if you cut the system, it doesn'
't matter much.
And so that would lead to, most likely,
very low level of consciousness.
I think that's what [Reads viewers
note] Yes. I should have typed
connectivity.
Yes.
If that's the case, that's fine.
Daniel: But higher complexity, which is
granted by some small world or some
sparse connectivity structure, higher
complexity is monotonically associated
with more consciousness?
Nao: That's not the case in IIT, and that
is true from the beginning.
And the easiest kind of example is to
have a two highly complex kind of system
that is loosely connected between them.
It's a kind of a situation where you are
interested right, in a sense like ant
colony, each ant has a huge brain.
Even though it looks extremely small, the
number of the neurons they have is more
than one million, right?
Daniel: I think in that order, yes.
Around a million.
Nao: Yeah.
So IIT would naturally predict that the
causal connection or integrated
information arising from this 1 million
neurons within I Am are going to be
really massive.
It's very difficult to disconnect in any
way, in any meaningful way.
However, interaction between a single ant
to the another ant has a much less direct
causal relationship. And therefore the
local minima or local maxima of the PHI
value is going to be very huge within
each ant.
But when you combine or when you treat
all these lots of ants, it definitely
does bring some kind of intelligent and
complex kind of behavior.
But phenomenality is not there at that
level.
Phenomenality, consciousness, lives
within this maximum level of integrated
information, pretty much like what we
talked about in timescale stuff.
We have a huge, complex and very
intelligent kind of behavior and
artifacts in the long time scale and also
short time scale.
But what matters for our phenomenology is
this particular several orders of 100
milliseconds that corresponds the maximum
of the integrated information.
Daniel: So you still have emergent
intelligence at the colony level, but
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
have qualia arising at that level for
analogous reasons why our qualia are at
the spiking timescale despite that being
only one of the nested timescales.
Nao: Exactly.
Daniel: Very.
Nao: IIT predicts that the intelligence
and the consciousness  qualia - is
completely dissociable.
And that leads to the commentary about
large language model.
Probably right.
Large language model is probably
structurally built to be very simple,
almost like probably Cerebellum in the
human brain, which accounts roughly like
80% of our neurons in the brain.
Out of ten to the eleven neurons in the
brain, 80% are in the cerebellum.
But even if you remove it or lose it or
are born without it, it seems
consciousness is not that different.
And the simple kind of prediction that
cerebellum is doing, maybe something
similar to the large neural[?] model is
doing. It's very modular, it's parallel,
it's not integrated, does a lot of
intelligent things, but nothing to do
with the consciousness.
Daniel: Very interesting!
Well, maybe in our closing sections, of
course, anything you want to share or ask,
, but how does active inference benefit
and grow from what you're sharing?
And how do you see things unfolding for
people interested in these topics?
Nao: Do you want to say something first?
Hayato: Yeah, I'm thinking, How would we
know?
Nao: Okay, then from my end I used to
have difficulty in thinking about active
inference or Markov blanket and things
like that.
But by broadening my perspective and so
becoming more generous, I started to feel
like more maybe some aspects of the
thinking and also formulation can be
relevant at least for the explanation of
the biological systems in various domain.
.
And if it's also useful to explain
intelligence or construct intelligence,
that would be great.
And from our work of the quantum quarry
of hypothesis, if quarry is something
that is influenced by its measurement,
then that aspect may be emphasizing this.
.
Usually Corey of consciousness is kind of
considered a passive construct.
Like at a given moment what I'm
experiencing static passive.
But now I'm more thinking about because
of this collaboration with the hat on the
other people.
That can be the case.
And it's more to do with the process.
And the process it may not be the kind of
the level of the active inference that
you are thinking like not the level of
the acting on the world, but more to do
with this state itself, influencing
itself might be some kind of important
insight to understand the quality.
Hayato: Okay, my comment is it is related
to the concept of states again because
expectation value I pointed out the
importance of expectation value but for
example what is the expectation value for
example the strength of causality or
something.
Then the problem of time scale is very
important.
So you can cause grain for example the
brain activity for one time, scale
another timescale.
So I think if IIT is correct there is a
good timescale which is of importance
great importance of choosing this
structure.
Then I think the brain information or
something causal structure should be the
good category and you can construct a non
competitive algebra and the state is
defined or something.
So the timescale is quite fundamental.
And on the other hand the state on the
category that is state on the category
algebra can be represented by some kind
of weight on arrows, the positive kind of
weight on arrows.
So the changing the state is the change
in the weight of these arrows.
The positive definite function.
I think the transition or the weighting
of this arrow is very at least
mathematically very interesting to
compare the active inference as a
mathematical point of view.
So good weight weight to the better
weight or something is very how to say
interesting to compare.
I don't have much knowledge about active
inference but it seems to me it is quite
useful to connect this level the state
change or something.
So yeah it is very interesting for me and
other thing is I forgot to the sad point
but yeah so yeah yes, as now already okay
point out I talked about measurements
instruments but the point of this notion
is probe system.
So measurement is always often considered
as a very direct kind of interaction like
the system and the environment.
But environment has some kind of probe
into the system then the interaction is
occurred with this probe and this system.
.
I think it is very analogous to the
quoria the case of so of course the outer
world is relating to the brain inside of
course at least process or the historical
or developmental.
But I think through perception or
something the brain has its probe over
the world.
For example this interaction is very hard
to say.
Interesting.
So measurement, the analogy to the
measurement theory may be some physically
within the.
Brain, but some kind of probe of the
outer system under this chorea is
interacting.
So I think it unifies picture, I think.
What do you think now, for example?
Nao: Yeah, that's actually very much
related to what I was actually
constructing this morning.
Nao: Yeah.
Nao: So I was reading this Ozawa paper
that describes the instrument, and I'm
getting better understanding what it
means.
But what he says is that every observable
a of a system S is identified with the
observable a tensor with the instrument I
over system S plus S prime.
So S here is the original system, and S
prime is the one that with any system
external to S.
And what Hayato was meaning is that this
S prime is probe system, which is a part
of the environment.
Right?
Hayato: Yeah.
Nao: And so here what this quantum, in
this case, quantum kind of system
description.
But it's also true for the quantum
cognition.
And in my case, it is also true for the
quantum coria hypothesis, is that some
kind of chore experiencing system is
interacting with the wired, but through
the sort of membrane, or sort of that
like a mark of branch like thing is
already filtering interaction as a
sensory input and out tension.
And this part itself is kind of
interacting with itself.
These arrows are the critical part.
And then if we translate that other way
to in our case, this correspond to every
coil a of a coil experiencing system S,
which is, in the case of IAT, it's called
a complex observer, a times instrument of
a system s prime, S prime.
And this S prime here, I think, will
include all the neural net processes that
support the underlying choreography, but
it doesn't really necessarily directly
include the external environment.
Many people start to do that, but if you
do that, then suddenly hallucination or
dreaming and things like that becomes
very difficult to explain, including too
much.
I think that corresponds to what you
wanted to say, right?
Hayato: Yes, exactly.
Nao: Yeah.
Daniel: Well, this is really awesome.
I very much appreciate that we could have
this conversation.
Is there anything else you want to add or
ask?
Nao: Thank you.
I also enjoyed and it was also good for
me to formulate my thoughts as well.
Hayato: Yeah, I'm very surprised.
Yeah.
Surprised me.
The how consistent our thoughts are.
It was just a surprise for me, maybe.
The conversation often goes, how to say,
diverge.
But our conversation has a very
surprisingly conversion.
So I think it's quite interesting in
itself.
I learned much from this conversation.
Thank you for inviting us.
Daniel: Thank you so much.
Hope to join on your channel and hear
updates on your research as things
develop.
So thank you again.
Hayato: Thank you.
Nao: Thank you.
Hayato: Bye.
Nao: Bye.